en el marco de la acción global contra
la militarización y la guerra
capitalista y patriarcal el Congreso
Nacional indígena convocó a una
movilización este 12 de octubre aquí
sobre Paseo de la Reforma para alzar la
voz por distintas causas Aquí está Jorge
Ángeles representante del pueblo Nagua
el pueblo originario de Zumpango en el
Estado de México Jorge Cuál es el motivo
de estar hoy aquí manifestándose pues
nosotros somos Víctimas de La amenaza de
extracción de agua de nuestro
territorios sabiendo que no hay la
suficiente en el acuífero Cuautitlán
Pachuca que es el que surte al
aeropuerto Felipe Ángeles estamos
defendiendo nuestra agua y estamos en
contra de que el ejército está
administrando los recursos naturales
Muchas gracias así es se manifiestan en
contra de Los Mega proyectos como el
aeropuerto como el tren maya en fin
distintas Obras Públicas que están
acabando con los recursos naturales
desde el punto de vista de estas
comunidades las hay de estas etnias hay
mayas hay zapotecas hay mixtecas en fin
de distintas partes del país también hay
estudiantes universitarios y un comité
de padres de los 43 estudiantes de
Ayotzinapa juntos en esta lucha por sus
causas
[Aplausos]